I saw in an interview they brought Phil
Hartman's which is the funniest Frank
Sinatra and he goes I didn't like that
they made frank mean yo Frank was mean
he was friends with the mafia you can't
be nice and be friends with the mafia
you're gonna be a [__] prick come on
man he was White Michael Jackson for a
whole [__] generation I love that
whole idea of like Frank wouldn't do
that you're like Frank was an old racist
was he a racist or was he normal for
when he was born that's because that
that's one thing I I make fun of people
that look at older white guys like can
you believe what they're saying it's
like yeah when were they born yeah like
what you should see as a white person is
yourself if you were born in 1938 like
this is what you would have sounded like
I will walk back to Frank Sinatra thing
because he maybe he was like Progressive
for his time or he's like I'm friends
with a black guy who's Jewish and
they're like whoa
whoa two and one what is this
what are you doing Frank you're making
all the boys
can't play the n-word poker that's what
we do